now staying in afghanistan where the
taliban has formed their new interim
government
turns out the biden administration was
duped by the kinder gentler taliban the
white house is angry that their cabinet
lacks inclusivity
as if that group that persecuted women
for decades was suddenly going to put
them in charge of the country
well it turns out the only diversity in
the taliban's ranks are the different
factions of terrorists they've imported
from around the region here to respond
is dan bongino host of unfiltered on
saturday nights at 10 p.m
um dan thank you for joining me tonight
it seems incredible
that the biden administration all these
deep staters who came from you know the
wesleyan gender program all these pajama
boys in the state department that they
actually thought that there was going to
be this new inclusive
taliban government and they're surprised
that women aren't included i mean what
are they thinking
they're not they're imbeciles these are
some of the dumbest people on planet
earth hey here's how this goes down
right they didn't really think that the
biden administration is an eclectic
blend
of probably five or six hundred of the
dumbest people in the country right now
and a blend of very smart people who
think you're stupid see that's the
problem and you have to kind of parse
out what i believe biden's genuinely
dumb but the people around him are not
they just think you're stupid so they
put things out on twitter to uh to do
virtue signal to their leftist wokes
goals hey listen look we're all about
inclusivity even with the taliban
meanwhile they're in a back room smoking
and joking probably smoking a cigar with
some coffee and tequila
laughing that how dumb people are to
accept this stuff biden is not a very
bright guy he may have actually believed
that but you have to remember rachel
these are people running the country
right now with a zero on the principle
scale i mean think about what they did
they abandoned american citizens behind
enemy lines with the taliban a bunch of
child bride taking medieval savages they
left our people there then they got out
using civilians who went over there on
their own dime to get these people out
and then this biden administration tried
to take credit after abandoning the
people for something they didn't even do
i mean if that's not on the depravity
scale a 10 out of
i i really don't know what is these
people are failures no absolutely it's
outrageous by the way now that we're
gone and the taliban's in charge we're
kind of starting to see a little bit
more of what the americans were doing
what the state department was involved
in
while we were there apparently they just
took down a blm and george floyd mural i
mean who thought that that was happening
in kabul um i mean this was being done
with taxpayer money and it's so
interesting to me uh dan because you
know the left used to talk about
cultural imperialism do you remember
that um i wonder if all the cultural
imperialism that our woke state
department was imposing on the on the
afghan people actually undermined the
government we were trying to support it
actually undermined what our military
was trying to do
yeah this is all best understood through
the uh david horowitz
anti-anti-communist lens right
i mean you have to understand like the
left has no principles what's
if you please if stop watching the show
now if you believe that if you believe
the leftist principles just turn the dot
because you're on the right they have no
principles at all their principle is
power the fact that they will run a
rainbow flag and yet celebrate a deal
with iran where they throw people who
are gay off buildings
i mean i don't understand like are you
an idiot like how does that register me
right yes yes all about the iran deal
they literally throw gay people off
buildings but we'll wear a rainbow flag
here and but here's the thing like you
have to understand like david horowitz
described this a long time ago the left
doesn't have principles they're only
about power we're the anti-communists
right you and i we believe in freedom
and liberty the left are the
anti-anti-communists they're just
against anything we're for they don't
care about freedom they'll say anything
to get power they have no binding
principles at all these people foam at
the mouth at the idea of getting power
if they have to throw the lgbt lobby uh
you know overboard to do it they will do
it they don't care
you think they have principles again you
are wasting your time it's like trying
to teach physics to your dog he's not
gonna learn you could be the greatest
physicist in the world your dog will not
get the physics leftists will never
understand principles period
period there are no principles there at
all you're absolutely right but it's
also very very dangerous dan of course
yeah well thank you for joining me
tonight you're always one of my favorite
guests thank you dan of course happy to
do it
thanks dan hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else